hypnosis is the state of Highly focused
attention it lets you think very clearly
very well
it also gives you a kind of cognitive
flexibility that used to be called
suggestibility you know and people worry
about that you know can you make me
think I'm a chicken and do all kinds of
foolish things
but that also means you're willing to
approach an Old Situation from a new
point of view to see it differently
that's what hypnosis is it's a naturally
occurring experience it doesn't just
happen when I dangle a watch and fight
we don't you know digital watches don't
dangle very well anyway so we don't do
that but
um it's a it's a an unusual state that
many people can get into and people who
are hypnotizable get into naturally so
people who are more hypnotizable get
lost in sunsets you know they uh get
absorbed in movies they miss dinner
because they're so busy working on
something that capacity to deeply
allocate your attentional resources is
something that happens in hypnosis yeah